so apparently something really
interesting happened on newsmax the
other day
let's watch well first mine was taken
down because we have all the election
fraud with these dominion machines we
have 100
proof all right so right off the bat you
have mike lindell spouting off some
crazy conspiracy theories about the
election which have obviously been
disproven
it was mike thank you very much mike
mike
you're talking about machines uh that
that we at newsmax have not been able to
verify
hilarious newsmax then cuts him off
because he's spouting some crazy
nonsense
we just want to let people know that
there's nothing substantive that we've
seen and let me read you something there
so as you probably know newsmax got a
cease and desist letter demanding a
retraction from smartmatic and dominion
saying that all this is crazy nonsense
so that's what they're reacting to here
while there were some clear evidence of
some cases of vote fraud
and election irregularities the election
results in every state were
certified finally mike lindell stops
talking